confession time I think I did quite a
bit to engineer brexit now I know Rachel
thinks at times I behave as if I'm lower
than a snake's belly but it's time to
fess up and face the music
my mayor Copa was prompted by this
week's news that Sky News quite rightly
is lobbying to ensure all political
leaders have to take part in future
general election debates my role we're
back in 2014 I hosted the first-ever
brexit debate where Nick Clegg and Nigel
Farage slugged it out over the rights
and wrongs of being part of the EU Nigel
Farage has been quoted more than once is
saying this got the entire Brits it
referendum issue rolling whether true or
not the opportunity to put politicians
on the spot and make them answer for
their actions or inactions must be part
of our democratic process the idea of
the independent leaders debate
commission ensures there will be no bias
politically nor towards a broadcaster
this has to happen
so pledges why not join in with Gordon
Brown and proclaim the I agree with Nick
C I agree with Nick I agree with Nick I
agree with me
[Music]
I'm probably committing Harry Caray with
my career here this is the sky campaign
however I think I completely get why TV
companies want leaders of it I
completely get it
I get it why politicians what it's more
exciting it's exciting well they don't
this is the key menu because gets the
more attention I get why TV companies
won because it gets them hybrids I get
why journalists want it because it gives
those bigger better stories but I'm not
sure how good it is for democracy okay I
think the danger is that you turn the
very serious business of politics into a
soap opera and I think I worry that
people will vote on style over substance
you talked about that Nick Clegg debate
now you know look look at the power and
Nick Clegg of got from that election
debate did the Lib Dems deserve the kind
of power they got as a result of that
debate no I don't think they did and
Nick Clegg himself at that debate he
looked like a very substantive
politician we all thought who's great
and when they analyzed why people
thought he was great the analysis came
back it was because he looked into the
camera when he was talking and he
remembered the first names of all the
people who ask new questions that made
people so vain judged him not his
policies they judged him on that
performance David Cavanaugh on that
still on those same debates he did very
badly and he was judged because they
thought he was too slick his suit was
too expensive his hair was too easy so
people may well judge on how people look
and not what the policies Michelle I
want to bring you in in a moment just
after we hear from this is being led by
Sky News John Riley is the head let's
say what he says this is all about doing
what's best for the voting public at the
moment the politicians gain the debates
typically the incumbent ducks and dives
the last minute and the broadcaster's
fearful of endangering their
impartiality are reluctant to point that
out the debates don't happen the answer
is an independent leaders debate
commission that organizes the debates in
a fair way well ahead of any general
election campaign beginning John Riley
head of Sky News Michelle I remember you
saying some time ago you thought that
election manifesto should almost be
league leader legal documents binding
documents so if you made under maybe you
having that debate this would speak to
that and your concern there wouldn't it
yes I feel a few different things about
this so I've always had a frustration
about the fact that potential politician
can stand up on a platform any platform
and pretty much say what they won to get
elected and then once they've got
elected based on what they've promised
they can just do whatever they want and
they've they've said oh I don't know
we'll we'll go against tuition fees and
people go that schools will vote for you
and then they go actually yeah well do
tuition fees there's no ramifications
apart from people say oh well we'll see
what happens in five years time the next
elections by which time most people have
forgotten so I kind of I've always felt
uncomfortable about people not being
held to account but I also have a
problem with the first-past-the-post
system right so I would actually like to
see the whole political system and
change to proportional representation
because but you're in favor of this
aspect just I think if you're gonna do
this yeah I think if you're gonna do
this you should have independent debates
because when I ran for election one of
the things that I must have is struggled
with and okay I wasn't trying to be
prime minister yet my apartment yet my
opponent would not my lab repair would
not debate me at all so any Hosting's
she would not attend and i found that
incredibly frustrating which i want a
bring you in on a journalistic moment in
a minute Greg there is a point at what
Carol says you might be elected style
over substance nobody really wants that
dude I think you get alexyss tylor
versus tub substance anybody really yeah
but I think though what I mean if you
look back over history it's the prime
minister of the day who by and large
skips these answers what John right it
was an absolutely it's a time is he
covered after trouble I didn't
particularly help me she's my at the
last election I mean she put down she
might have done better if she'd had the
devices there's quite a good bit Nick
Clegg makes quite a strong argument for
why you should have them we don't have a
presidential system we have a
parliamentary system but actually we
have a present presidential style of
politics increasingly in this country so
the person the woman or the man who's
like to become prime minister or indeed
they're I said Deputy Prime Minister is
terrifically important and at the moment
we don't you know the way in which some
of these debates are constructed don't
really put the individuals under the
magnifying glass in a way which I think
the increasing presidential ization of
British politics demands yeah and I
think he's got a point there he's got a
point that actually we journalistically
it's we all talk about the leaders yeah
basically
therefore we should actually see them
debate with each other
Rachel and I'm a journalist you were
once it's it's fair to say that we have
two party leaders now but more than ever
try and dodge really proper inspection
proper debate great rightly points mr.
Jeremy Corbett isn't exactly pouring
into the TV it's even more important how
these debates isn't it I mean at first I
didn't like the idea of having mandatory
sort of presidential style leaders
debates but actually I really come
around to it
remember back in 1960 of course
Michelle's too young actually I was I
wasn't even born there was the Nixon yes
debate and kennedy debate and there was
not another presidential leaders debate
for another 16 years because the
incumbent realized it you know the
intriguing thing about wait wait you
will know this on TV
yes everyone on radio thought Nixon had
won everyone who watched on television
so Kennedy he won't because Nixon is in
and the fact is that you know we do have
presidential style politics and Nick
Clegg is right but what I have been
around during an election campaign and
it is far more important that this is
run by an independent panel than by spin
doctors who put through you know a crack
of people waving banners in a corner of
a hangar to look as if you know
Cameron's having a rally it's much
better that's controlled not by the
politicians but by the broadband we
don't see you before we move on we just
have to see a clip actually of the 2010
sky debates
[Music]
good evening from the Arnolfini in
bristol and welcome to the sky news
leaders debate round 2 of the first ever
televised prime ministerial debate in
the UK well the three men who want to
run the country after May the 6th are
here and raring to go
so please welcome David Cameron Nick
Clegg and Gordon Brown
[Music]
back in 1964 Alec douglas-home refused
to do a TV TV debate and he said it will
turn politics into an arm of show
business
well politics is now chauffeurs can I
just go back that we've been talking
about a presidential style election yes
it did I think that's part of the
problem that is my one of my biggest
criticisms that it's different in this
country in America it is the president
largely who makes policy in this country
and pay still help make policy and
they're very important in all this and I
think what I think also what these
leadership debates do is if if the
leader [ __ ] up on television all those
campaigning MPs and the constituencies
all those helpers those party members
who are out on the doors in all weathers
trying to put some measures home it
doesn't matter what they say after that
if the leaders cocked up on television
people not listen to them anymore the
leader is the one who's accountable and
I think it undermines those people and
what they're what the work they're
trying to do and also you said people
dodge properly tried to dodge probably
maybe they're not dodging inspection
maybe they're just not very good on
television look at the people who have
been good on television Tony Blair was
like the Pied Piper we all followed him
because he was a great orator and look
what he turned out to be a manipulative
Masonic liar
IRRI so he was great on television I
mean one of the things that I get really
frustrated about is no I don't I mean
what do you have do you have a leader
from every single political what I'm
talking about because I don't like the
fact that it's always Tory velar but and
maybe like a little bit of Lib Dems
throwing stars did you do it I told you
I do I don't like class the first I
would have proportionally agree the
truth of the matter of these debates
chants are in a sentence if you would if
you go in as a conservative you probably
come out as conserve if you go in as a
labor you come they probably don't
change that much today I think that's
probably right although I do know one
Labour MP of former Labour MP who thinks
he lost because of the debate in 2010
because then he thinks he lost because
you remember Nick Clegg suddenly became
very popular after the first debate yes
and then didn't do some well in the
later ones and they went back down again
anybody was doing postal votes tended to
do it
that first week and he lost on this guy
lost on the postal vote because he said
they will suddenly vote even we just
need to make a couple of things clear
firstly um Tony Blair who has good legal
connections probably dispute the fact
that he's been labeled of liars who will
say that why don't you get involved by
going hashtag make debates happen you
can get involved on hashtag make debates
happen